who in your view this is the toughest
question of this interview uh is the
greatest hip-hop artist of all time
maybe give some candidates oh wow who is
the greatest hip-hop artist so
you know i don't know if i'm qualified
to make that bad because you you know um
uh
when i
i have to go back to like gil scott
herron you know like people think of him
as one of the fathers of hip-hop
um
that's my all-time favorite you know um
and people like chuck d from public
enemy some of the things that they were
doing i was really digging but even
though uh i was digging like public
enemy um but even they got it wrong on
drugs even gil scott herron got it wrong
on drugs um but um they were doing so
much other good stuff uh it helped me to
develop as a person um and so um
uh
i think uh
like my son is a hip-hop artist now i
think those those folks who are in the
game now they might be they are a lot
more qualified to talk about who's the
greatest hip-hop artist i i'm not
qualified the evolution i mean have you
tracked the evolution from sort of the
90s with uh wu-tang and tupac and biggie
and then to uh what we have today so
there's just been a crazy amount of
progress that's like almost difficult to
track yeah i mean i really love what
they're doing i like what they accept
the part where uh they get over 40 and
they become [ __ ] cops on tv i mean
other than that i dig what's that about
yeah i don't understand that you know
but that's what they do again those
uh this sort of glorious glorification
of cops
that's dangerous for a society
and and those cats who do that kind of
thing you know i have a problem with
that is it all sort of to push back a
little bit because i come from the
soviet union where there's a huge amount
of corruption and when i see
what's going on with cops in this
country there's a lot of proper
criticism you can apply but like
relative to other
uh places
this is well on in on so many ways this
country is incredible
uh is your criticism towards
cops or towards what cops are asked to
do yeah towards what cops are asked to
do
cops provide the shield for politician
and those in power uh absolutely because
i was in the military i spent four years
in the military and i did what i was
told to do and i was ignorant and
and thought i was doing the right thing
and i
did what i was told to do and so just
like these guys are doing what they're
told to do
but no i my real beef is with the power
structure the folks who are telling them
what to do
and also those those the the folks who
go play cops on on television um that
imagery that sort of um
glorifying cops
that's a problem in a democracy
yeah all sides of the glorification of
the drug war is a problem yeah
you